- Au chemin Roxham,
des camionnettes blanc
immatriculées en Floride
déposent maintenant toutes les
semaines des deman
- Ça, c'est nouveau.
- Janet McFetridge est
la mairesse de Champlain,
où est situé le chemin Roxham.
Selon elle, une industrie
sur le dos des migrants.
JANET McFETRIDGE, mairessede Nek
- C'est un grand commerce.
Un réseau de beaucoup
de personnes différentes
et tout le monde profite
financièrement.
quququququququququququququququqe
de ces camionnettes.
- On était 13.
On a quitté là-bas vendredi
et on est arrivé samedi.
- J'ai vu quatre voitures. Des
mini vannes.- - - - - - - - - -.
- J'ai payé en "cash",
j'ai payé enshshsh".
- Frantz André est un défenseur
du droit des migrants. L'ampleur
de ce commerce le préoccupe.
- On a appelé un passeur en
prétextant être migrant.
On a posé la question de la GRC.
On a prie rendez-vous avec l
propriétaire de camionnette se
présente comme journaliste.
Il accepte de nous ren
de grosses demandes.semaine
facilement 80 personnes.
Deux gars qui travaillaient pour
moi sont
business à eux.
- Les gens viennent d'un peu
nenenenenenenenenenenenenenenen.
- Gagner plusieurs milliers des.
Officiellement le responsable de
la frontièt t t surtout faire
pour assurer des passages
frontaliers légaux même vers le
Canada. Pourtant, des sources
C'est que estime cet expert en
immigration.
- Les américaines font Nada,
zéro. Pourquoi empêcher les
mes s s nécessaires pour le
ce système et d'expulser ces
gens. Ils sont aveugles de façon
volontaire.
- Le gouvernement Trudeau arefue